oh [ __ ] Oh oh no oh no no no no no no oh
oh it's everywhere everywhere oh oh
it's soaked my notebook oh he was my
favorite he was so young how could he go
damn it now it smells like coffee
everywhere cute coffee why do you have
to be delicious and help me wake up how
could this happen to me
I made my mistakes hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to with
the addition of markiplier dance with
caution and remember if you don't dance
with caution you're gonna ruin your
favourite notebook and then be sad for
rustier playthrough but either way this
was made by the same guy that made the
other with the addition to marklar games
fantastic fan games I love them to death
they're a lot of fun and that's when I
said vite to the ice cream puffs Liuba
boo boo oh you're so funny mark I don't
get it
don't worry wait only intelligent people
do okay what hi wait a minute that's an
insult
shut up Wade so um what a gamer we all
gonna play tonight mark I'm Danny Danny
sex bang yeah can we play Mega Man X I'm
egoraptor how about trove oh I wanna
play for noisy fridays happy we heels as
it zu race jontron e're jontron no I'm
being serious guys uh why don't we just
play that new multiplayer RPG dicks and
demons
I wanna play Dixson demons I vote yes
okay fine
who brought the game Wade said he was
gonna bring it
why I didn't mark did show your face all
Wayde Aaron said he was gonna whoa man I
don't even know what that game is huh as
if I'd know anything about dicks
god dammit guys I'll go get the game
later that same evening thanks Bob
all right guys the gaming cabin is just
through this terrifying forest of doom
okay geez mark why do you live so close
to these woods what was that noise
ah whoops what did you do Aaron I made
of a spilled some beer on tiny box Tim's
grave oh I forgot tiny box Tim was dead
in this game it was dead oh damn it
Aaron I'm sorry mark huh
it'll be fine I'll clean it when you
guys leave a mark I have a question why
do you keep your gaming room all the way
in the woods don't question my logic
John I love the faces that this guy
pulled for my character cuz we just
getting wait what can we just get moving
of Carl's can we just get moving it's
almost 11 o'clock Batman good idea
yamimash alright oh oh I'm moving now a
bit of beer spilt on the cross luckily
most of it have been soaked up into the
ground now tiny box Tim will come up as
a beer drunk zombie great sorry mark I'm
a bit drunk eh even though Aaron doesn't
drink alcohol at all this forest better
run it is smooth 60 frames per second
cuz I'm running in a smooth 60 frames
per second well just follow you just
lead the way just promise me you won't
stop to check every rock and tree oh oh
are you sure are you sure are you sure
is safe to go out into the fallish mark
of course buddy it's perfectly safe this
pond is very soothing and calming that
being said let's get [ __ ] up
alright oh yes I'll [ __ ] you talkin
[ __ ] up with you then haha he's a sexy
bastard and I won't take advantage of
anyone when there
I wouldn't do that anyway especially not
you Danny that's really creepy that's
really creepy let's get going mark by
the way did you bring any Doritos
specifically Cool Ranch Doritos to take
care of the werecats from the where so
from this animation over here check out
the where can't animation okay anyway I
looked at your face wait oh haha very
funny I don't remember what was that I
wasn't looking
gotta love lettuce not as much as meat
but it's still pretty good on the side
some of my prized lettuces
they look pretty average how dare you
John John if you want a whoopin it's
coming your way
runway drunk Oh potatoes the potatoes
but that's an old reference salvia
strong with the help of fruit and
vegetables kids it's true I went online
learned that these fruits are really
quite poisonous I probably shouldn't
have given a big batch of them to
CaptainSparklez at least now I'll be the
best gentleman indeed yes okay anyway
yeah it's a terrifying force to doom
that I just so happen to live behind
I missed you tree stump okay bye oh this
forest looks bizarre and weird oh I've
got a train behind me okay mark let's
not start this well oh damn I draw my
soda yes Aaron mr. butterfingers over
here oh it's a save point sometimes I
don't even know how I make the sounds
that I do you know I've always wanted to
be a tree really I think Mark's been
smoking some trees if you know what I
mean Oh give me beatboxing a bubucaca
Boop did you poo approve it blew her
trees so grand
boy what a horrible cough mark okay
thank you Marcus doesn't look like a
forest loom it's kind of pretty yeah we
could even go for a picnic here a picnic
that's not very manly cuz that's all I
care about now um my tongue slipped what
I meant to say was uh to kill a sick
chick what wait wait what are you
now I'm seeing the terrifying part okay
this is bizarre it's great to know the
trees can't kill you tree falls on
EWTN's it is not a lies a giant lie is
the biggest lie you've ever told me oh
no you can't do this to me you can't I
just got done with this ball carrying on
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
blabla I'm not even gonna read all the
stupid bull alright I'll read the stupid
bull what a beautiful tree mark as much
as I like you staring at trees could we
possibly get moving oh my god so sorry
Danny let's get going
indeed let's go don't actually play the
game here not look at trees okay so one
of them kills me mark are you sure you
want to continue of course I'm too manly
to back down now yeah why would I now
what was their secret was there god damn
was there a goddamned secret if there
was oh oh Jesus what the hell is that
thing
mark we should probably go I'm starting
to think this isn't such a good idea
yeah let's draw the line here yeah I
think you guys might be right I don't
know I think we might be able to rush
past it at the right time great idea
Danny let's do it oh okay well oh well
that changes everything
rock-hard abs baby I didn't stomp it
with my abs why was that a thing Parag
is in pain no mostly oh oh okay good to
know that all the things that nature
have a backstory okay I'm not gonna read
all the bull here wow I didn't even mean
to do that but I guess he's dead now so
I just have to live with that decision
for the rest of my life if you want to
we can check out my yard down here first
cuz apparently I have to go through
these woods every day when I go out to
get to my yard huh so uh so why is this
yard all question mark II why uh why
okay so uh Oh Rach you are so cool Oh
Rach you always rule Oh Rach you never
drool Oh Rach you go to school he'll
della runs okay
bizarre you know there should be
something more interesting than a rock
here to look at it's completely optional
if you want to waste everyone's time you
know MMR can we just go
but this pillar is so intriguing now I'm
gonna skip everything I'm done looking
at your bull maybe you shouldn't touch
that mark what's he sick moves what
man-wolf why is there a man wolf what
the point of the oh nice boxes holy [ __ ]
sort of looks like wolf job oh okay oh
okay okay we're gonna beat the dreaded
wolf's job here we go
ha ha okay Mar bars party was victorious
I found a lucky cat why did I find a
lucky cat what's the point of a lucky
cat way it's a pretty little kitty oh
it's such an adorable pretty little
kitty hmm Virginie d bye
sing with me mark hit some other [ __ ]
tree I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you mark
you're gonna die soon oh that was a
lovely song there Rach [ __ ] okay then I
guess we're pretty much done here if the
whole point of that was to defeat the
wolf job I think I accomplished my goal
let me just save over here before I do
that
okay so now into the gaming cabin cuz
this is what me and my friends do every
time we get together and people fly
across the ocean stay at my bizarre
cabin in the woods and then all die uh I
think you might be Nene to some
renovation mark mark mark hold me
this place is creepy yup I'm gonna I'm
not gonna hold you Yami Danny on the
other hand Danny do you need to be held
let's just get gaming shall we alright
oh where in the hell is gaming it's a
bit of an uninteresting book we'll get
hammered later on rope in case I ever
want to hang myself
well that's dark I always just keep that
around don't worry about me it's a
broken pot box has a family Vance oh of
course
ow boo Lance ah the pain
and everyone died ah wait oh ma come on
if I didn't know that these games were
fun in the past but maybe not now but I
wouldn't be playing this Bob and I went
skating today we only broke all the
bones in our body cool from skate three
something tells me the gaming rooms on
the other side I don't know what just my
instinct in that this is my cabin if I
step on this will attract a wolf oh oh I
get it
that's from the last one Burke serves
Berks I love ger sperms I think I can
see my house from up here okay good for
you John fine oh me oh wait how think it
here already what the hell happened
that's a tiny thing well now I know that
everyone can teleport let's get on with
dicks and demons all right I put the
game in cool I've been looking forward
to playing this game may I have the
first girl uh no I put it in I get to go
first
um okay go ahead
oh that's awesome that's really cool
oh okay oh he's playing I'm not playing
case you didn't know Aaron's favorite
game was Megaman Oh Aaron I don't think
that's dicks and demons uh-uh
of course it is mark just look at the
end uh yeah while Megaman X is 10 times
better anyway so what did you do with my
game I gave it to John over there uh
John that game was made of bubblegum
guys I had to eat it
John what did you do but I spat it out
it tastes really bad don't try it
John where did you spit it out ah ah
relax mark I didn't expect this place to
hold power for very long do you have
some sort of generator mark there might
have been one in the other room Danny
you come with me everyone else can do
whatever the [ __ ] they want okay all
right cool me and Danny private time cuz
apparently I'm super gay for Danny
doesn't mean we can't have fun with it
like honest Annie right
and so Marga bar and Danny had why hey
I'm gonna overcome it with positivity
and love I am shooting all of my love
towards you through the internet do you
feel it in your heart do you feel it
that's my love for you my undying love
okay so what's gonna happens I'm just
gonna avoid looking at anything in the
environment in case it kills me oh that
was scary
hmm let's see what this read taking left
or I may determine the end one may have
oh oh
okay so oh is that all about the fires
out
is it indeed so in the here mark I don't
know oh we can check can't we maybe it's
only my house what's this do
hey Danny maybe this is a generator it
doesn't look like a generator well it
doesn't hurt to try
hey this marks on the walls let's see
one says one on the Left says up and the
one on the right says down warning this
decision will distract eclis change the
story of the game choose wisely which
way should we push it ah right baby
rights always right right here we go Oh
No
oh no oh there we go that was a little
dramatic
okay I'm falling now
Oh Danny now Danny don't leave me Danny
now okay
I seem to be falling very relaxing and
sexually is that's how I do everything
that I do totally handsome and awesome
at all times
mmm how are you doing yeah you loon good
mark
mm-hmm I can't sing like Danny Oh No
yeah yikes good thing I landed on my nan
stabbed but don't know how I'd stand on
anything else though how do I look there
we go okay Zota how the hell did radical
soda get down here I have no idea
this barrels seen better days I'm not
gonna look at anything oh no someone
died here I'm too manly to be scared us
what was that don't kill me don't kill
me bro I'm not looking at anything
car tracks huh I guess my only way out
is used to flow them I ate my best
chance to get out of here everyone
knowing the tracks always lead out okay
cool except maybe this was out all right
cool that's a dead end
what
what what happened what happened I don't
know what happened what happened what
I've done that by me again what the hell
is happen what happened
goddamnit I need to find out how to get
out of here I don't know what happened
what just happened I don't understand it
what just happened okay fine
these look like research notes di if hor
all shavon has escaped from the facility
ensure all measures are to be tak hmm
that's all I can scavenge from that page
here's another weave can some security
measures and now in order to ring your
ad to the Y from the pillar the rest of
it's all ripped up
so I need to get the k-wire from the
pillar Zhou your scene well this box
full of gold did this used to be a gold
mine or something
mmm-hmm okay so from the pillar cool
rock I thought it was a pillar nothing
much of interest here what about this
pillar
maybe if I pry this loose mm I got a
silver key I'm so smart and whatnot
OOP all right is there anything Pat is
that a Dragonball can I make a wish okay
mm-hmm red orb seems strange for
something like it to be here I better
take it for safekeeping or not I'll just
leave it there and they oh nine seven
how's your chat fully been released with
little to no problems
di on the other hand has too much
potential to release now more tests will
presume okay cool Mao to brief test oh
oh eight eggs Goldust what do they need
this for computer console of some sort
okay cool bags of gold dust maybe I
could take some with me but I don't
because I'm a dingus let lead doctor oh
hey hey well how's it going there dr.
Roberto mcbutter chicken no right good
name for a doctor looks like a crazy
sort of person although I wouldn't make
harsh judgments like that let's see if I
can hack into it or something ma'am
damn it it didn't work why didn't that
work
I had all the Assumption in the world
that would work okay what's in here
the last potion I drank took away my
wings I'm not taking another chance - I
could get wings Oh green ball I wonder
why it's here hmm
the mystery Oh that subjects Am I I owe
you one
- ma o - seven disintegrated within
hours subjects Dao two three and D a31
had similar results da I performed MA
sparing troubles for new parts it would
seem the DA hold strong too dear neither
am i inform blue sector abouthere made o
two threes bone-density it appears it
could be useful for physical tasks okay
why are you trying to make a monster or
something I probably shouldn't go
drinking random chemicals okay then
bizarre looks like a story of some sort
I saw old the horses they were eight of
them on that hill they took all four of
my diamonds whilst ravaging the seven
paddocks of clovers
what the hell's that mean a single
dragon stood at the base of another hill
three patches then joined it okay weird
all right green room
yeah as if I said but come on now we
think I'm stupid or something but I
can't lose yours okay
so what am I supposed to be doing here
locked my silver key isn't working maybe
there's another key around here
somewhere
oh whoa
pipe down there okay but look at this
place nobody's been here for a while but
then why is there pot dere was the army
mash down here chop
I gots a bit of a jump of assumption to
make uh yes
see looks like it's been sitting here
for quite a while huh
Ben was spelled incorrectly da o-67
breathe test Oh three what does it mean
good question some sort of stand without
a flaws how about the pillars that's a
good question I was wondering that looks
like a fireplace with a sign on it says
furnace mmm-hmm
there must be something in the green
room something that I overlooked okay I
think I got it the the code is in
relation to these clovers and diamonds
those things on the walls are clovers
and diamonds so it says four diamonds
seven clovers okay four and seven I
should probably remember this story
because it might be important for later
I'm taking pictures with my phone taking
advantage of technology for my advantage
to play a game that I'm playing right
now good great okay so what that means
is it's seven four seven seven four this
should be the code seven four Evan Evan
hey it worked
ha ha ha genius look at me hello this is
nice it's a purple room an incredible
find if I do say so myself counsels are
real quite rare these days we ate him
okey-dokey Mao nine seven released the
hell I hope nothing is in here with me
cuz that's definitely not something
that's probably happening
squishy Oh to have a blue couch okay
what do we got here
locked it as a note on top the lid
remembering is key to any scenario
drinkin do not forget okay so I got a
drinking random concoctions it's always
good not just yet hang on hang on
Mao nine six gender in explicitly
transformed whilst in the creation
process whatever what caused this is
unknown but it may have something to do
with the extra even it seems like
something has ripped up the rest of it
that's not what that said at all but
that's what I read okay a purple ball
have a blue one at home but what are
they I didn't notice the blue one at
home what were you talking about
okay there's less shrinking let's move
the story forward here oh my good oh hey
horse two horses horse horse badger
dragon horse horse badger dragon horse
horse horse banjo dragon horse I know
this I know this cuz I took pictures of
it horse horse badger dragon horse that
is the most bizarre thing I've ever seen
everyone see with me in the comments
below
horse horse badger dragon horse horse
horse badger dragon horse
you better be shouting it out louder
else it doesn't count horse horse badger
dragon horse horse horse Oh
badger dragon horse bang oh I'm so good
I got an athlete key oh look at me I'm
so fancy and free ok the console seems
to be a bit broken but I don't care
about that because I'm moving forward
with this story but first I'm gonna save
more Ronald cool soda and let me get up
okay to the way I think I'm all out of
time for this episode I'm looking
forward to more of this and I'm not
gonna interact with anything that's
gonna kill myself so what you like thank
you everybody so much for watching I
really do enjoy these fan-made games I
love playing them and especially I love
playing in these series because I have a
ton of fun with them so I hope you're
enjoying it let me know what you think
in the comments below and let me know if
there's any other fan made games that I
haven't played just yet
I know there's got to be a lot out there
that I've missed but hey I really do
appreciate you guys taking the time to
make these games
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
I totally forgot about that what the
hell was that
a vision mark